تنتج فرنسا
130 ألف طن سنويًا من المحار ونحن
نعيد استخدام هذه النفايات أو جزء من
هذه النفايات بطريقة ذكية
[موسيقى]
نستخدم المفهوم الموجود منذ
قرون الآن، هذه مجرد
اللوحة البيضاء التي يمكنك العثور عليها  في اليونان على سبيل
المثال، يمكنك أن تجد في
المنطقة العربية حيث اعتاد الناس على التسخين والسخونة الزائدة
باستخدام هذه اللوحة الفنية،
أننا نعكس فقط 90% من
الأشعة الشمسية وبدون
تحويل تلك الأشعة إلى
حرارة، فنحن قادمون من بريطانيا وهذا
تمامًا مثل  حسنًا، عملية النفايات الصناعية
حول المحار هي في الواقع
فصل الجانب العضوي عن
جانب الكالسيوم، ثم نعم، نحن
نطحنه جيدًا ونعيد استخدامه مع
مرض محدد للغاية، حسنًا، ونحن
ندرج هذا في نعم في
اللوحة الأولى  أه مجرد
انخفاض في درجة الحرارة، سيكون الانخفاض هو ما
لاحظناه مع
عملائنا - من 6 إلى - 7 ويمكننا أن نتجاوز ذلك
اعتمادًا على حالة
المبنى وتكوينه وهو
بالفعل أعني ضخم جدًا لأن هذا
يتجنب  لاستخدام مكيف الهواء على سبيل المثال، والأمر
الثاني هو أنه إذا
لم نستخدم مكيف الهواء فهذا
يعني أننا نقوم بتقليل استخدام الطاقة
يمكننا تقليل الفاتورة واستخدام استخدام الطاقة من 20 إلى
50٪
آه تقليل أو
إزالة الكربون بما يصل إلى 36 كيلوجرامًا من ثاني أكسيد الكربون لكل
متر مربع، نحن الشركة الرائدة في هذا
السوق، لقد اقتربنا الآن من مليون
متر مربع، وهو ما يمثل الكثير لأنه في
فرنسا يمثل ذلك ما يقرب من 100 أه
سانت ديف فرنسا، وهو ملعب فرنسي كبير
لذلك بدأنا في فرنسا
بالطبع ولاحظنا أن فائدة
هذه اللوحة
يمكن أن تكون
أعظم في جميع أنحاء العالم، هذا
منتج متخصص، هذا سوق متخصص ولكن
هذا يجب أن يتوسع بشكل واضح ونعم نحن
فقط بحاجة للتأكد اليوم أن الجميع
يعرف عن ذلك بشكل جيد وأن الجميع يعرف
فائدة ذلك بهذه البساطة